la tnt la télé numérique terrestre
s'apprête à effectuer ses premiers pas
dans quelques mois les premiers tests
techniques sont prévues demain depuis la
tour eiffel le point sur ce qui
s'annonce comme une petite révolution
numérique dans le paf frais avec monteil
dominique bonnet 1949 le premier journal
télévisé de france en anglais dans le
texte
à l'époque le choix n'existe pas une
seule chaîne et pas de couleur 2005 le
nombre de chiens explose voici la tnt la
télé numérique terrestre une avalanche
d'image lancé officiellement le 31 mars
prochain
la tnt c'est la télévision numérique
pour tous est à dire trois fois plus de
shed qu'aujourd'hui sans abonnement au
total quatorze chaînes gratuites dont 8
inédite comme m6 music nrj tv ou direct
côté service public vous connaissiez
france 2 france 3 et france 5
vous découvrirez bientôt france 4 la
nouvelle venue mise sur le
divertissement le sport et la musique va
être à nouveau en direct au printemps de
bourges
pendant trois soirs de suite aux
francofolies au festival des vieilles
charrues
etc etc un grand festival par mois et
puis nous allons rediffuser des grands
événements sportifs pour recevoir la tnt
une bonne vieille antenne suffit ensuite
il faut investir entre 80 et 150 euros
dans un boîtier comme celui ci en 30
secondes d'installation à vous les 14
chaînes mais pour certains il faudra
patienter beaucoup plus longtemps car le
réseau tnt couvrira d'abord les grandes
agglomérations
les premiers tests techniques de la tnt
commence lundi
depuis la tour eiffel
[Musique]